from extreme
Heights to extreme
depths millions of species clash in
Savage battles of
survival animals fight tooth and Claw
against their own
kind to Inn food
territory and rights to the
bloodline
in the wild there are no
rules this is Animal Fight
Night up above the Wilds of Alaska few
animals fight as high as our first
Contender the solitary bald eagle Soares
up to 10,000
ft surfing Rising thermal currents
minimizing Wing beats to save
[Music]
energy traveling up to 270 miles in a
single
day but when bald eagle meets bald eagle
it's midair combat between Nature's
ultimate flying
[Music]
machines it's
fall this one-year-old bald eagle yet to
develop the iconic white feathered hat
faces his his first winter without Mom
and
Dad food is
scarce a river full of sammon and water
fowl offers a chance to stock up for
[Music]
winter the young blood takes out a duck
but a squadron of adult Eagles have him
in their
crosshairs young blood will have to
defend his dinner in an aerial dog fight
for which bald eagles are perfectly
designed his extremely light skeleton
weighs no more than a bar of soap
minimizing the load he needs to carry in
Flight muscles that make up half the
Eagle's body weight power a 7t
wingspan astonishingly an eagle Wing
pound-for-pound is stronger than the
wing of an
airplane
an enemy Ace is on young blood's
tail he climbs
steeply sacrificing speed for
altitude Eagles have around 7,000
feathers most can move independently and
have their own nerve and muscle
system aerodynamic feathers direct air
flow over the Wing's Leading
Edge primaries spread out like fingers
secondaries move to very drag tail
feathers serve as a
[Music]
Rudder outf flown the enemy Aces try a
new
tactic using a grip 10 times that of
human the Eagles lock claws in a deadly
game of
[Music]
chicken they plunge into a death
spiral the Ace
bailes Young Blood hangs on to his
prize another Ace tries his
luck diving at up to 100 miles per
hour this intense flapping uses 20 times
more energy than
soaring the older Aces run low on
fuel young blood's youthful stamina
holds
out but it's not just a meal he's won
he's earned his wings as a top
gun at least for now other birds will
think twice about taking him
on as we go down to the ground for a
different kind of dog
fight our next Challengers have roamed
America for over a million
[Music]
years
they can run up to 40
mph leap distances of 13
[Applause]
ft ruthless Predators they will stalk
prey for a whole
day and when coyote meets
coyote it's no less
bloody
[Music]
winter in
Montana food is hard to come
by but this coyote Chief has a sense of
smell strong enough to penetrate the
Frozen
landscape he's hit the
jackpot it's a bison
carcass a supersized meal that could
last the pack for
weeks but a rival gang has gotten there
first they'll have to settle this the
hard
way the chief summons his
pack with food this scarce neither the
chief nor the gang leader can afford to
let this one
go their body language sends out its
strongest Threat
Signal muscles attached to hairs
contract to make them stand
erect the spine arches
[Music]
upwards all this gives the illusion that
the animal is larger than it actually
is the lips curl back to flash sharp
teeth the gang leader makes the first
move a classic technique called a grab
bite
he shakes the chief by the Scruff of the
neck to try to subdue him so he can go
in for the
[Music]
kid the chief shakes him off and
counters a slash to the shoulder sees
the Rival leader
off but the Rival pack is still feasting
the Chief's gang members provide
[Applause]
[Music]
backup a rival pack member goes for the
chief he loses his grip the chief bites
the rival's tail to slow him
[Music]
down the Rival Retreats back to his
hungry
pack the chief celebrates his prize and
calls for his pack to help
[Music]
[Applause]
him Ethiopia's Simeon
mountains the roof of
[Music]
Africa our next Contender is a close
relation to the baboon
[Music]
it has the largest canine to body length
ratio of any mammal on the
planet the gelada monkey also known as
the bleeding heart
baboon and for the males when bites
break out it's all out
War
a troop of gelada monkeys takes in the
view this 10year old male has two
females and 12 children in his
protection but there's trouble up
ahead a gang of males is on the
approach
their Crimson bleeding heart chests show
their flush with
hormones they have their eyes on the
leaders
females gelada females are fickle easily
swayed by male attention
the dawn is constantly fighting to keep
his family
[Music]
together The Bachelors gear up for the
fight the da flashes the pinks of his
eyebrows to try and Ward them
off it doesn't
work he Bears his
teeth The Bachelors won't stand
down the dawn has to take them
on but he's
outnumbered he tries a new
[Music]
strategy he shakes the branches and
postures to intimidate the
baters they don't scare that easy
he decides to wow them with a display of
[Music]
speed the play works it looks like
they've backed off for
now he returns to his females
but he's dropped in their
estimation in an act of desperation he
picks up one of the babies to impress
them but the baby falls inuring his
[Music]
arm all the Dons won is the Wrath of the
females
the bers have another
[Music]
chance they take their turns taking the
leader on trying to bite his
face in gelat of fights injuries can be
fatal not only is the dawn outnumbered
by The Bachelor pack he's lost the
backing of his
females it's a losing
[Music]
battle the new leader quickly stamps his
authority on his new harm
[Music]
the dawn is
demoted but he still gets visiting
rights to the
kids his flaming red chest will soon
Fade to a weak light
pink but the new leader had better watch
his
back the females are always open to a
better
offer our next Fighters have no time for
Monkey
Business defending their underwater
hideouts is a serious
matter they are animal fight Knights
superheroes their
superpower the fastest punch in the
world at a speed of 50
mph it can crack more than just
shells it's powerful enough to smash
glass when mantis meets
mantis it's time to smash each
other in the warm shallows of the
tropics a female mantis shrimp is holed
up in her Coral condo guarding her
clutch of eggs
to stay one step ahead she uses her
second best superpower her
eyesight the Mantis has the most complex
eyes in the animal
kingdom each one moves
independently and can see five times as
many colors as
humans she spots
trouble a white maale mantis is on her
doorstep he plans to to force her
out so he can use her burrow to shelter
from Attack if she's expelled she and
her unborn Offspring will be exposed to
Hungry
Predators the threat triggers a series
of fluorescent patches to fire up across
her body the colorful display a warning
[Music]
system it doesn't
work so she unleashes the fastest punch
in the world
there super
weapons arms that hook back
springload and latch in place until
they're
released more than 50 times faster than
the blink of an eye accelerating faster
than a 22 caliber
bullet the water around them
boils even if the punch misses its
Target the shock wave alone can kill an
opponent but the Mantis has it
[Music]
covered with a personal body armor so
tough it's even been studied by the US
Military
while special fiber coating their limbs
keeps everything in
place a spiral-shaped skeletal structure
spreads the force of any
impact before the female can
reload the Intruder counters quickly
with his own super
punch in the Mantis world if you
smooze you
lose the females lost her home and her
eggs but she's alive and has the chance
to find a new home and spawn
again our next contender's weapons are
certainly not shrimp
sized 10 ,000 ft up in the Israeli
desert home to the Nubian
ibec this Oldtimer is King of the
mountain he has 20 females for his
Harum but he can't afford to rest on his
[Music]
Laurels throughout the Mating Season he
will defend himself from Challengers to
his
throne and he's well equipped for the
fight
able to LEAP three times their own
height climb sheer
Cliffs walk Ledges just 1 in wide they
cling on with suction like
Hooves their horns are 4 ft
long they grow 1 and 1/2 in each
year they are awesome weapons and they
need to
be because when breeding rights are at
stake jealous male IEX go for
blood this hot-headed Nubian Ibex Buck
wants the old's
Herold before they decide to go to war
they have a shoving
match it's a way of sizing each other
up and testing their opponents
resolve ridges on the horns prevent them
from
slipping Nubian horns have nerves and a
blood
supply breakages are Agony and could
cause them to bleed to
death the ICS check each other out
they'll only fight if they're the same
size and it's game
on the Young Buck gains the upper
ground he launches a barrage of flying
head futts from on
high because of the Steep Rocky terrain
charging is too dangerous rearing up on
his hind legs allows him to throw most
of his body weight into the
blow
the young buck is trying to Ram his
opponent
[Music]
downhill he lands a well- aimed blow to
his opponent's
[Music]
skull their neck muscles tense up to
prevent the spine from twisting on
impact they're strong enough to support
their 33lb
horns the Oldtimer twists his head to
block the
blows he hooks the Young Buck now he has
the upper
ground he shs his opponent
downhill on a steep gradient this can
cause a buck to plummet to his
[Music]
death the youngster concedes
defeat the old's status is intact
with a Harum 20 female strong he could
father up to 40 Offspring this season
while the Young Buck has another lonely
year
[Music]
ahead living alone is a fact of life for
the next
Fighters with only a couple of months a
year to secure their bloodline when they
do meet it's underground
Mayhem their claw CLS are 116th of the
length of their body they can dig up to
15 ft per
hour armed with 44 teeth when they turn
on each other a single bite could spell
a bloody
end in a forest in Germany 4T down
[Music]
this Subterranean Soldier spends 90% of
his 3-year lifespan
underground he eats his own body weight
in earthworms and bugs each
day most of the time he operates
alone but it's breeding season and his
sights are set on a neighboring
female he plans to knock through to her
burrow and mate with
her in an underground Network filled
with enemies hairs on his face body and
tail detect
[Music]
vibrations his nervous system is so
smart it can read the difference between
dinner a predator and movement above
[Music]
ground each nostril has directional
smell in other words they smell in
Stereo his tracking system is telling
him he's on a collision course another
male is breaking into the same female's
burrow this won't end
well when two mole males meet it's
Underground ground
combat their main weapon their
claws designed for shoveling and tunnel
Warfare the soldier bats the enemy
forcing him to beat a
retreat outside the confines of the
tunnel the soldier engages a different
weapon a vicious
bik
mole blood isn't like human blood its
clotting agent is less
effective a deep cut can lead to a
dangerous bleed and weaken the
fighter the enemy decides the risks are
too
great triumphant the soldier goes to
claim his
prize but now he's got another fight on
his
hands female moles have combined male
and female reproductive
organs which means above average
testosterone and above average
aggression but the best thing about
fighting is the making
up the soldier departs it's going going
to be a whole lot of earthworm eating
days before he can enter her nest
again and our next Contender will fight
to the death for nest
[Music]
space in this peaceful looking Japanese
Canal lurks one of the world's biggest
amphibians the giant
salamander 5 ft long weighing 55
lb the ultimate underwater
Predator as a large animal who hunts in
confined spaces Giants have highly
unusual
mouths each side of the jaw opens and
closes
independently letting them catch prey
without opening their whole
mouth a second row of teeth on the upper
jaw secures struggling
victims they'll eat anything that
moves but the Giant's Diet also consists
of a special
delicacy other
Giants this adult male has a nest in a
pipe Outlet he's guarding his brood of
eggs they take 3 months to hatch
Giants take a decade to reach adulthood
and can live for 80
years nearby another male hunts for a
nest to
raid giant salamanders can't focus both
eyes on the same thing at the same time
only seeing a blurred outline of
shapes instead Giants use sensory organs
covering their bodies to pick up
movements in the water and even detect
the weak electric field that animals
emit but today the Raider hasn't
detected the
guard who
attacks in just 50 milliseconds throat
muscles contract creating a vacuum that
sucks in the Raider with a gForce
equivalent to an accelerating dragon
his mouth clamps shut the Raider has no
means of
retaliation he faces
decapitation stress triggers the
Raider's defense system a chemical
secretion from Poison glands across his
body designed to repel aggressors it
smells like
ammonia the Raider escapes with his
head the guard has protected his
eggs now he better
chill soon he'll have up to 500 children
to worry
[Music]
about 2,800 M South lies the island of
sui home to perhaps animal fight night's
weirdest
[Music]
animal this shy creature is native only
to four Indonesian
[Music]
Islands its name in the Malay language
means Pig
deer meet the
babusa so far not that
unusual but the males have something the
females
don't extraordinary
teeth his lower canines grow sideways
out of his
mouth stranger still his upper canines
grow up through his snout piercing the
skin and curved toward the top of his
head forming handle likee tusks which
never stop
growing they look like a protective cage
around the
face in a rainforest clearing a herd of
babusa take a
bath mud
soothes kills parasites and provides
vital minerals
this male and female are enjoying an
afternoon
flirtation he has a perfect set of tusks
12 in Long symmetrical and
unbroken a sign of good jeans they are
exactly what every female wants in a
male
[Music]
babusa but a jealous onlooker doesn't
like being the third wheel
tonight there's going to be a tus fight
in the
[Music]
jungle babusa fights start
slow standing cheek to cheek they shove
each other with their
shoulders the fight's
on it's not the way most pigs fight
babusa fights are dangerous those sharp
teeth can easily Gore an opponent's
neet and hook him clean off the
ground they rear up on their hind legs
jabbing their heads to shove their
opponent
away but babusa tusks are brittle and
not fixed firmly in their sockets
they look like they are designed for
combat but they are an easily broken
danger
spot a male with damaged tusks is far
less likely to
breed the Challenger has maneuvered his
canines into a precarious
position the young romantic has a knife
up against his
throat one thrust could slice the
jugular no woman is worth risking his
life life
for his Challenger wins the female's
approval he'll head over to the mudbath
to join her as the duel with tusks ends
a surprisingly deadly duel with claws
begins animal fight night's next
Contender can be found enjoying the surf
on this Florida
beach it's commonly believed that they
are named for their pale color
which changes throughout the
day Atlantic ghost crabs pint-sized
contenders who pinch above their
weight with 360° Vision they eat animals
their own
size their claws can exert 14,000 lb of
pressure per square in five times as
much as a car
crusher and when it comes to defending
their Burrows from each other they're
not afraid to use
them this male is extending his burrow
to attract
females by the time he's finished it
will be 3 ft
deep
but his fiercely territorial neighbor
doesn't like his choice of real
estate these guys may only be 2 in but
this beach isn't big enough for both of
them the neighbor decides to give the
Homemaker a piece of his
mind his eyes positioned on swiveling
stalks the Homemaker can see all the way
around his head and easily spot incoming
[Music]
trouble the neighbor can be on to him at
a speed of 10
mph that's like a human running five
times the speed of
sound most crabs can only move
sideways but ghost crabs can maneuver
themselves eles in any direction even
forwards the homeowner makes the first
move they strike with their
claws each one is designed differently
the larger one crushes the smaller more
agile one handles and
slices
the homeowner tries to flip the neighbor
onto its back a crab's worst nightmare
it exposes him to becoming a bird's meal
before he writes
himself the opponents decide this is one
neighborly dispute not worth dying
for both return to their
Burrows the home owner stays King of the
Hill there'll be no neighborly barbecues
this year
but one of the most surprisingly vicious
contenders might even visit your cookout
in The Gardens of America prows the
domestic cat cute cuddly and one of
animal fight night's most Savage
Killers for the cat territory is
everything Turf can be around 5
Acres a hunting ground marked with urine
feces and scent from facial
glands cat's ears contain over 30
muscles allowing them to swivel
independently in the direction of a
sound leaping five times their own
height to catch
prey backward-facing spines on their
tongue hook into flesh they kill more
than a billion Birds a year in America
alone the 7-year-old topcat on the right
has a
trespasser a 4-year-old Punk looking to
hijack his
patch heart rates rise to 140 beats per
minute nearly twice the human
rate this growl is designed to
intimidate but the punk isn't backing
[Music]
down to defend his territory the black
and white topcat lunges for the Punk's
neck using four dagger likee canines
designed for stabbing into
[Music]
prey the strategy snap the Punk's spinal
cord
[Music]
the punk breaks
free both cats are agile
Fighters twice as many vertebra as
humans combined with loose skin that
acts like baggy clothing lets them twist
their upper body
180° to always land on their
[Music]
feet the punk changes
tack using his sharp front claws curved
to maximize
hold now un sheathed from under his paws
to drag his rival off the
ground an extra layer of skin and
padding on the stomach offers
protection top cat's owner steps
in the pp beats it if he wants to mate
he'll have to take over someone else's
Turf while these guys bear their claws
some Fighters keep their weapons well
hidden a riverbank in
England
home to this Serene
creature most of the time they glide
through
life but nothing Ruffles their
feathers more than a territory
dispute when it comes to defending their
nests the loser faces death by
drowning
a happy family event is
unfolding this Swan couple have paired
up for life and now they are welcoming
their first ever batch of chicks to the
world but something catches the father's
eye a male swan is on the
approach he wants the area for his own
[Music]
family the father tried to warn him off
he puffs up his wings an act of
aggression known as
busking a few
[Music]
hisses but the Invader keeps on
coming he needs somewhere to make
signets of his own if the first time
father loses the family home his
newborns could perish
the father makes the first
move trying to beat the Invader with his
wings hidden bony Spurs on the outer
Wing joints deliver a slicing searingly
powerful blow strong enough to break a
human
leg next he goes for the invader's
neck its length and flexibility
make it vital for foraging for food on
the
riverbed it's also the hardest place to
defend the Invader can't duck out of the
clinch the father has the upper
hand but the Invader deploys his beak
biting down to block the father's Wing
blows
the beak is a defensive tool serrated
tooth likee ridges bite down as the wing
comes at them making it difficult for
their opponent to strike
again he pins The Invader
down with a move swans use to drown
their enemy in water
fights the father has a new problem on
his hands
the invader's
wife outnumbered he's going to need
backup the mother of his newborns
abandons their
nest the invading female is
oblivious the invader's wife is no match
for the new
mom their chicks now safe Mom hurries
home
triumphant just in time to see chick
number four hatch blissfully unaware of
all the action it's just
[Music]
missed